each [ __ ] Tom Cruise is this gonna stay
focused cheers hoping am I'm gonna stay
focused absolutely not but my dog is
sleeping on the ground right there like
a Kurd she loves being in the way
kurtsyn way
hello welcome to this my name is Grace
Abba if you didn't know this is my
channel it's great lovely to have you I
will take every second I can get with
you until you forget that you left this
video running and you don't know which
tab it's coming from and you found the
tavern up by if you're still here great
today I'm doing a cooking video I
haven't done cooking this on a very long
time I roll up my sleeves as if labor is
about to happen but no you are going
back to school and one of the greatest
classes school has to offer is lunch
allows you to experience nutrients for
your growth and it allows you to
silently observe the social
psychological patterns the average
teenager lunch is the best of times and
the worst of times so this is the back
to school lunch making video and try
somewhere to keep this intro brief and I
just can't because I'm more of a boxer
person boxers or briefs you're already
gone what does it matter now and the
spirit of DIY back to school videos I
thought I'd teach you how to DIY your
lunch using one of the cornerstones of
school lunch pizza here's my thought
process behind this in order to make a
lunch item that was less of an actual
recipe and more of just a format to
allow you to experiment with all kinds
of dirty nasty flavor profiles so today
I'm making an illusion pizza that makes
no sense to you I know
by the end of this video it will is that
incentive enough to stick around
no admire your honesty let's begin I
went on my Facebook page if you guys
don't know I have a Facebook page and I
asked you guys what do you eat for lunch
and I look through all of your answers
thank you to those who said their
feelings too real too soon too bad I
don't have the emotional spectrum to
comfort you so it took a lot of the
answers that you gave me on what you ate
for lunch and I bought a lot of those
things
oh my battery's dying are you kidding me
I can't it universe you don't want this
pizza to happen we'll be back in like
ten minutes you won't even notice oh
hello my video pardon the interruption
just the while I'm giving you such a
great tutorial I may as well give you a
couple ideas for things you can do while
your battery charges one go for a run
like what I just did I'm better than you
skidding to maybe while you're running
you want to listen to some sweet sweet
tunes or if you don't like music why not
listen to an audiobook that's right
you know this shenanigan already
audible.com works a lot of youtubers
myself included they gave me this vandal
URL audible.com slash grace for you to
go download your first audio book for
free my books on there lots of other
youtuber books are on there such as
boiling and why Iowa and royally and
really weird so make sure you're gonna
get my crown clash grace and download
your first free audio book okay birthday
pizza for the toppings I basically got
toppings that can be divided into two
categories savory and sweet because for
lunch you want your meal and then treat
yourself
so here's what's going to happen I'm
going to make two types of sweet pizzas
and two types of save receipts and based
on what you talked about my facebook
page you eat for lunch let's do this
first we start with our crust you can be
a Pinterest [ __ ] make your crust from
scratch or you can buy premade crust
which is what I did this is where I
figure out a plan plans are always best
when they're figured out in the moment
on camera
ah-ha what let's turn our oven on
I'm never going to pick a pizza how do
we put the pizza I'm turning my oven on
to 325 degrees that sounds like pizza
degrees one corner of my favorite
feature is going to be mac and cheese so
let's make some mac and cheese woo add
water now for this and I try for three
and a half minutes on another half of a
pizza I'm going to put hot dog hot dogs
why don't you have very basic childlike
instructions like the macaroni and
cheese did Oh crazy I can't just stay
with me I'm gonna melt some butter man
oh yeah okay whoa and that'll our cheese
this is cooking yes very organic shade
of orange
since the mac and cheese side we're
going to melt some butter in the
microwave well are you coming in lacking
so much but I'm going to take my melted
butter and I'm going to paint it onto my
crust and then I'm going to shake on top
I got a crap Parmesan cheese rosemary
and garlic flavor whoa but be careful
with this rosemary and garlic flavor if
you want to major in kissing in high
school and if you do you're an idiot
because you cannot major in things in
high school painting painting thing ah
wrinkle it yeah
yes good now we are going to put our hot
dogs on 1/2 you should probably cook
your hot dog but I'm just a man
dog will cook in the oven when the crust
cook you know what happens when you
assume you learn you're not a robot okay
now we're going to cook all our savory
beads across how long have you two
crests good form in the meantime let's
get started with our sweet crust that's
a great prostitute named simply I put
some savory Susan on the other pizza
crust I mean put cinnamon sugar on these
pizza crusts yeah calm down
I'm not that smart I'm just so smart so
I'm gonna put some more melted butter on
these crabs
sorry Michelle Obama we owe for crisper
crust free bake 10 to 12 minutes how
long has it been no one know time is an
illusion but I don't have another baking
sheet one time I bought a pizza stone
because I thought I was going to be that
kind of person and I've never used it
because I'm this kind of person look
that's what it's for right Bruno's into
the oven is the only kind of video
you'll find on the Internet where it
gets better when you put the tops on
that was a great joke you guys that was
a really great joke so just acknowledge
it by subscribing and liking we're back
so our hot dogs already cooked on this
side but what goes on a hot dog ketchup
and mustard let's do it let's see if we
can get a better angle for you Oh whole
new world oh I hate the impending fart
noise ketchup that was the bottom you
know the liquid that comes out of the
mustard before the mustard actually
comes out there is no God great
there's our hot dog pizza feel free to
add and relish or whatever the [ __ ] you
guys put on hot dogs what else you guys
eat for lunch some of you sent salads
and that's how I realized that some of
you are liars but I got this Caesar
salad from Target go Caesar dressing
Oh beautiful chickens it's a chicken
Caesar Wow up goose gets a piece of
chicken some Parmesan cheese they're
going to say for pizza done what else
I'm macaroni and cheese remember this
guy again this is the DIY part so feel
free to put whatever toppings you want
on your pizzas have a pizza party with
your girlfriends or your guy friends or
your invisible friends and just go to
town don't go to town stay in your house
we're sick an imagination is the only
station you need to pay for on cable oh
oh this is the video in which I've
officially gone crazy congratulations
it's about time a lot of you said then
you eat sandwiches so I got some turkey
some mayonnaise let's make a turkey
sandwich on this this turkey smells like
farts you put mustard on turkey sandwich
sure today you do no mustard there we go
all of our savory pizzas are done look
how beautiful she put it in her mouth
now let's move on to our sweet pizzas
these sweet pizzas are focused more on
breakfast type foods cereal and what I'm
going to use is jet puff Marshmallow
cream as the milk substitute that's a
fun prostitute name - milk substitute go
jet puffed marshmallow cream but you
guys look great party party party
responsibly BAM peanut butter and jelly
oh what a beautiful say peanut butter
and jelly looks kind of gross
next up granola bites I'm gonna use some
peanut butter as my adhesive oh my god
my battery is almost dying so we gotta
go quickly oh these look beautiful
unless you're not least fruit for this
I'm going to use some honey no no
I'm good I remember that song that's got
the word honey in it now I throw some
blueberries on you should probably wash
your blueberries before you use them but
if you have a camera battery that's
dying in front of your face you just do
what you can
strawberries oh these have to be cut yay
beautiful look at these guys there you
go there are all of our savory sweet and
these your pizzas you're probably like
why the cheese encode infusion pizzas
here's where the fun game comes in
around this you make all these pizzas
with your friends and then you buy a
bunch of these opaque lunch boxes in
which you can't see what's inside you
come up these pizzas and you put one
savory one sweet in each one of these
boxes put them into your refrigerator
mix them all up and every morning just
grab one for lunch and you'll have no
idea what's inside and what you get to
lunch it'll be a surprise as to what
combo of savory and sweet pizzas you've
got like you had amnesia amnesia pizza
let me show you yes
uh-oh should have to knit four knives
through this hi I'm mustard on the shape
fluff oh god what happened okay then one
savory and one sweet pizza into each box
put it in Betty now mix them up BAM
here's a dramatization of what could
happen to you I don't know I'll take
this one all I do within here I have
enough self-control not open the lid
Bing Bing Bing time for lunch okay
freeze but do you have for lunch I don't
know of the grace let me look Oh turkey
sandwich pizza and cinnamon toast crunch
pizza Wow really glad I played that game
on myself now I have enough excitement
to get me through the rest of this
sheesh ass day in this brick hell hey
there is my amnesia pizza I hope things
dance and join us if you did give it
thumbs up subscribe leave a comment down
below if you're gonna try these Pizza
feel free to post them on Instagram and
Twitter and tag me in them like I'm a
goddamn beauty guru I just changed your
lives
I don't know thank you good job
hydrating